i do want to go back to something you
said a second ago about this not
being some kind of referendum uh or
having anything to do with either
quarterback's
legacy first of all i'm not gonna let
you down play that because it's too sexy
and i don't know that i've ever been
excited about a match-up quote-unquote
match-up
uh between two quarterbacks like i am
about this one
i do think and mahomes
he could ball out if brady gets a
seventh
at my home's expense
it's gonna be it's hard i mean we
already talked about how harder it's
gonna be for my holmes to
to catch brady for anybody for that
matter to catch brady
but if brady gets a seventh i do think
it's gonna be
jordan lebron-esque because okay it's
not gonna be about patrick mahomes this
shortcut like look okay look brady just
beat aaron rodgers it's not because
brady stopped aaron rodgers
hell it's not because it's in the second
half because of brady at all but
there you go i think you're i think but
already taking
thinking like i'm saying you're
weakening your own argument
nope that's not what i'm doing i'm
acknowledging the other side i mean i'm
acknowledging the
the reality of this give it a little bit
before i go courtesy then come back
okay exactly a little little debate 101.
i'm giving you
i'm giving you the other side and i'm
going to get a little weight right
yeah so it's not it's not saying that
uh it's going to be some kind of a of a
of a ding on patrick mahomes
the reason i say is lebron mj is like
and i'm not one of these people michael
you know this you know how i feel about
championships in team sports
but what i'm saying is that and we
talked about this at a certain point man
you just can't ignore the number
whether it's russell's 11 or jordan 6
for that matter
or brady and going to 10 and maybe about
to win
seven you can't ignore that number and
if brady gets a seventh
presumably having to outperform patrick
mahomes
not be him not defend him
because obviously they don't face each
other but presumably having to go
toe-to-toe if not outperform patrick
mahomes
it's gonna be real hard for my holmes to
win enough super bowls
to supplant tom brady as the goat like
lebron
right like there are some people who
believe lebron james is the best player
of all time
there are other people who will never
see lebron james as the best player of
all time
because of some of the losses it's
unfair
but unfortunately that's just it that
them the breaks that's that's how we're
going
alice what's your standard though what
standard are you looking at you've said
before you're not looking at
championships so if you're not looking
at championships
you can make the argument now that
lebron is better than jordan if you're
not if you're not looking at
championships
if you say i wouldn't make that i'm
looking at lebron james
all the things he's able to do all the
positions that he's been able to play
and the length of uninterrupted
uninjured time for him his first major
injury was out with the with the lakers
year one right missed those what 18
games
but other than that you got this 36 year
old guy
who's just still just playing at a high
level and if you look at all the numbers
somebody can say all right lebron's
better right now and championships don't
factor in there are some people there
are some people saying that
i don't i'm not one of those people okay
no you're not there
i you know what mike i told you that and
this is like
this is like a little off to the side
just kind of put this little note in
your margin and we'll come back
there's no such thing there's no such
thing as off to the side remarkable no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no this is mj
i'm gonna say i'm not going there i'm
not i'm not gonna hover there
okay the car is running the car is
running uh-huh okay
yeah you got my change okay i'm out okay
is cars running i'm just i'm gonna sign
that thing i'm gonna keep going
all right i'm changing i think
i am a lebron over jordan person now and
i wasn't
at the beginning of this program
september
debut brother from another
i was not there i think i'm there
all right all right anyway car's right
go home you can't don't
you can't just anyway so we can okay
stay with your car analogy
let's park that let's park that we're
going to come back to that
we'll come back but meanwhile we need to
talk about this foot massage
and by foot massage i'm talking about a
possible
seventh super bowl where nobody else has
won more than
four and that's not to say my homes can
never win
eight it's just hard to imagine but okay
you know that's that's what that's what
they play for right
but he didn't have to i'm saying that's
what i'm saying
while six or seven super bowls no he
shouldn't he doesn't you're right
and again i i know it sounds like i'm
talking on both sides of my mouth i'm
not
this is a little bit this is what i'm
getting at michael this is what i'm
getting okay let's go you know i'm
consistent on this i'm consistent on
this
and there are no absolutes this is what
i'm getting at
i'm not saying that seven super bowls
would be the end-all be-all
but it means something like a foot
massage it means something
right you know i've given a million
ladies a million foot massages and they
all
meant something like if you get seven
brothers
look at my mother football listen man
it's when you combine seven super bowls
with the numbers with the numbers
yes yes it's
it's it's going to mean something it
will it will
okay i'm going to close the door on any
future goat arguments
but it will be hard for mahomes
to ever have the equivalent of being 43
years old
with a new team in a pandemic
your first year with this new team
taking them to the super bowl
and then in the process besting
the up and coming goat that's that's a
hell of a thing for brady's resume that
i even
i can't
he's good he's good on the resume he's
good on it already and not just the
championships
but this whole tb12 method and getting
your sleep and
and you know not messing around with
strawberries and sugar and all that kind
of stuff
like that it's great because he's still
playing
he he is actually the walking he is the
embodied he's the greatest ambassador
for the tb12 business that he could find
nobody else is a better ambassador than
you put on the game tape well how do i
know this works why don't you sit down
here let me show you some film there i
am
uh number 12. i'm number 12. look at
that look at that throw
so that's already said from his
perspective
but how would it change from homes i can
see how you know getting seven for brady
would really be good but if if mahomes
wins again it's back-to-back
championships first guy to do that since
brady
uh did it with the patriots um all right
has two championships is he now the is
he the best
he beat the best now he's the best too
he's on he's on he's on his way
he's on his way he's already down here
here's how i would frame it well
but it would it would hit a speed bump
if if if
he didn't win this one and again i
listen michael
i i know we we are reducing this
conversation to quarterbacks and
championships this is like
i get it let this but just play along
here all right yeah play along
i got you if if you're patrick mahomes
and you come out the gate with an mvp
two super bowls and presumably to go
with it two super bowl mvp awards
and one of them is you took down the
greatest of all time who's still at the
top of his game so we talk about
rarified air
we're not talking about mahomes right
now we've said this already this is not
even a hot take we've already
established this he's already one of the
greatest players to ever play
quarterback he's one of the greatest
we've ever seen
already he's in the conversation when
you talk about
the greats of all time my homes has
already ain't got to throw another pass
but when you're talking about that top
spot the one that brady occupies
okay that some foolish people
try to like nitpick and and and and
split hairs
and say well he's the goat but you know
aaron rodgers is the great
it's brady okay it's brady it's
brilliant
if you try to come for that i just don't
know that you can
suffer a loss at brady's hands it might
it might be oversimplifying it i just
feel like if you're trying to get that
you gotta get these two and you got to
stop brady from getting a seven
like brady can't create more separation
from you at your expense
and rings aren't the end-all be-all
that's why i've been putting off aaron
rodgers
i'm not saying that but like you said
the other day at a certain point you
just can't ignore them
yeah especially it ain't like brady just
along for the ride it's like he's
driving the bus
you know yeah at some point
um we got to figure out what that number
is
like is it three and under like so we
got three rings
and and and so you got three rings and
the other guy's got one
you're like okay let's not talk about
rings okay
but once it becomes over three
like you got five this is kind of hard
to ignore
yeah well rings don't matter dude like
guys i told you about this book that i
used to
so remember back in the day at the
library let's hate the story
remember back in the day at the library
um you
they would have the books with the card
in the back and you would it's about it
like you'll always have
a library and you would say they write
your name or they stamp it on there yeah
yeah you can see who had it and who
turned it in and who checked it out
okay there was this paperback book it
was a paperback book i wish i could find
it
and it was the kind that was like one of
those little you know real
quick books that had like a split on the
cover
and it was called dan marino and jill
montana
dan marino and joe montana and and you
got that
i was michael smith michael smith
michael smith michael smith michael
smith michael i should have just kept it
and paid and just bought it or bought it
off the library
i was what are you looking for he said i
just
loved that book you know why i love that
book
but you know why i love that book so
much because i loved
dan marino and you couldn't tell me dan
marino wasn't as
good if not better than joe
hannah oh i was preparing for life
ever hot take artists i was a dan marino
guy
throwing through at me if there was
twitter back then i'd have been like at
me
okay i was a dan marino guy but at a
certain point i had sense enough not to
sit up here and argue
that mourinho and montana were in the
same class
it's like okay man like you know he just
separated himself
it just you know it wasn't just 84 it
was 88 it was 89 just it's okay
this is montana right reno was fantastic
it's montana
yeah mourinho you know it's montana yeah
you know montana and everything and
likewise
like mourinho just go out y'all ever see
him
maybe the past one right there dan why
it's always somebody else's fault
but then when i was somebody like you
keep stacking chips
it's like all right man you can't you
can't argue i told you the other day i'm
gonna stop with this aaron rodgers is
the
the best position yeah as gifted as he
is i mean it's like
dude got six championships and going
another i mean even i got to come up off
of that yeah
yeah it's different it's different for
quarterbacks too it's just a different
standard
we're just holding them to it's almost
like we don't look at them as play their
players their coaches their motivators
we just bring a lot to the quarterback
conversation that
we don't bring to say wide receiver hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube make sure you hit subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you